i'm sorry this fire is so [ __ ] hot it  is really hot yeah i told you can we  open the door no no no no no no take  your shirt off take your shirt turn the  fire off no take your shirt off you  don't want me to take my shirt off glenn  why don't you sit over here then don't  because are you a fatty  rob your nose is a little red i have  wind burn or maybe that's i don't know  dude i don't know  wind burn just on your nose no no no no  that's literally alcohol  yeah you're flush was my note was my  nose red before the alcohol no  it has fired up since it looks it looks  like someone has slapped  another nose onto your face  you know what it is i think it's the i  think it's the fire  [Music]